we have a very important mission for
tonight we must use stealth and cunning
to infiltrate the human world and
retrieve
go-kart
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up let's go from Seth Rogen
comes a movie that crushes for
absolutely every age
amazing insane all right tell me more
it's effortlessly cool and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this year
[Music]
that seems very dangerous see danger for
breakfast actually I eat pizza with bits
of waffles on it
with the funniest cast ever assembled
surprise
oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do this
[Music]
awesome
we're brothers We Fight Together
we're just getting started
[Music]
yeah she sounded like a leader I do oh
I did sell accessories and you ruined it
Turtles
remember don't let any human see you
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters August 2nd
get your tickets now